miss alsace miss france
[Applaudissements]
miss france 1987 hu et pourquoi donc
retour quelques jours avant l'une
d'elles sera élue miss france dans
quelques jours elles sont venues de 38
régions harry intra muros compris
décembre 1986 c'est une grande première
l'élection de miss france sera diffusé
pour la première fois la télévision et
en direct pour assurer le show
guy lux et une idée ah oui c'est la
première fois que les téléspectateurs
aussi seront amenés à élire miss france
miss france 1987
[Musique]
comment ça va se passer l'année dans sa
lettre à 47 80 du temps les spectateurs
ravis
les miss défilent en tenue régional et
en maillot de bain évidemment elle se
présente âge profession est important
signe astrologique
le public vote en appelant europe 1
partenaire de l'événement un partenaire
qui s'y perd entre classement et
dauphine et là c'est le drame
la troisième dauphine troisième dauphine
c'est c'est résultats attendait parce
que là on a revu cette femme petite
erreur au final une mise quitte le
plateau
attendez attendez ou est-ce que j'en
suis 2e dauphine deuxième dauphine
qu'est-ce qui se passe
de 6 à gauche qu'est ce qu'elle à notre
liste elle se fâche tabac une mise
proteste dit que pourtant pour la
première fois c'est le public qui vote
et personne d'autre après dix minutes de
cafouillages en direct nathalie marquay
19 ans est élue miss france cette
première élection télévisée a été une
catastrophe
vous savez qu'elle a été lu dans des
conditions un peu difficiles la nuit de
la saint sylvestre à paris elle
s'appelle nathalie marquay elle a 19 ans
19 ans mais malgré cette première
chaotique
chaque année l'élection de miss france
est en direct avec le vote du public
le show est aujourd'hui bien rodée et
assemble des millions de téléspectateurs
pas moins de 7,3 millions en décembre
[Musique]